if you look at the polls and it does
feel as though two party portraits is
back between the Conservatives and labor
in the rest of the UK and in Scotland
between the SNP and the Conservatives I
mean they live Dems and other smaller
parties look like they're being squeezed
out you're gonna be at games we're going
to make games and the selection you're
gonna make games we're going to make
games in this election in Scotland we're
going to make games and don't say we're
going to make games on my old form a
part of the country the rest
how many guys you're gonna make I'm not
going to start naming numbers but what
we can actually guarantee is we're going
to grow in this election campaign
because we've got that package of
policies that is going to be popular in
things like making sure that we look
after people in their old age when we
are proposing a modest penny of income
tax to invest in social care we're
proposing a big investment in education
one of the top priorities for the
Liberal Democrats that's a big policy
for us making sure that we have a
benefit system that cares for people
isn't as harsh as the Conservatives are
planning we can turn back the
Conservatives in this campaign in
Liberal Democrats so the only party are
actually talking about weekend games
from the Conservatives we broaden that
they're just trying to hold on yeah
because you had such a low base to start
with and you don't feel as though you're
being punished still for those perceived
sins of going into bed with the
Conservatives that last time around that
instead well look what's happened since
I mean what have we had slashing of
renewable energy investment so the
climate change agenda in this country
has been set back by the Conservatives
we've had massive slashing of benefits
we've had a big change in terms of
brixon none of that would have happened
if Lib Dems are holding back in fact we
stopped them doing this when we were in
power so you can see very very clearly
the consequences of the conservative
very quickly labor teams looking back at
that time and coalition is there
anything you'd have done differently
any mistakes of course I'm looking
forward